do you love superheroes do you wish you
could see where they live work and play
let me be your guide to NYC the MCU how
you doing I'm Barry vanetti president
CEO and non-union bus driver and if you
know me you know I can't get enough of
the Avengers even war machine join me on
a non-refundable trip to the best
Avengers sites from all over the world
and by world I mean New York cuz every
hero matters lives in a 20-mile radius
the st. mark Street for some reason are
you from clean Brooklyn yeah that's
right
suck it Philly you'll see exotic locales
such as the security barricade outside
the old Avengers Tower then for a better
view we'll hit the roof of the Foot
Locker where my cousin Jemma works got a
dynamite view right into their cafeteria
you used to be able to catch Black Widow
take you down to chop cheese like
clockwork Plus gem will give you a 10%
off a pair of Asics with minimal rat
damage so everyone wins most tours leave
out dr. strangers sanctum sanctorum over
on Bleecker because it's not open to the
public and it's shielded by magic but my
sister's husband does their drywall and
he'll leave the door unlocked from 2:00
to 3:00 so keep a low profile and grab a
souvenir of unspeakable power personally
I don't mess around with magic stuff
ever since Scarlet Witch made all the
mutants in this universe disappear oh
you don't remember mutants you must be
crazy crazy like a fox
time your visit to catch the annual
stark Expo
it's one part TED talk one part adult
entertainment convention additional
purchase necessary to get in know any
schmuck can show you the harbor where
spider-man and Iron Man saved that boat
but I know what Gaiden owes the janitor
of Midtown science and he says
spider-man goes to school there hand to
God
have a blast debating which kid is my
pick is this Brett but make those
arguments quick they only let a bus full
of adults look at kids for so long
before they start asking questions we'll
stop for lunch at the schwarmann oint
where the Avengers all late after saving
the city from Loki
including the bathroom where Thor took a
dump after he ain't all that shawarma
legend say you can still smell the lamb
time permitting would the Brooklyn to
see the very alley where Steve Rogers
used to get beat up every day
it's an artisanal ginger ale brewery now
reach out and touch that history also
the Starbucks across the street was the
SSR lab where Peggy Carter worked during
the war
sometimes there's still good stuff from
the estate sale in the trash oh yeah
this has gone on eBay and for our
Platinum Plus tours we'll even throw in
the street-level heroes no one cares
about - after dark we'll drive around
Hell's Kitchen to bang on some trash
cans long enough Daredevils gonna show
up smelling like a dead ninja it's like
a feral cat that one we're all these
ninjas coming from that's Midland
financial circle there used to be a big
hole there full of dragon bones but now
it's filled up kind of a letdown so run
like Quicksilver to reserve your tour
today
but don't get shot like Quicksilver
what's at your thing in which case we
offer our bargain risk-takers East New
York package cuz who knows how much
longer this city will even be here
before it all get the sky beams again I
mean my cousin is a guy made of rocks
who had a hook-up into Asgard and then
BAM whole place was just gone
so yeah call today
you